mon raymond un coup de coeur mon chéri
ouais j'ai un coup de coeur pour un
chanteur que j'ai découvert pendant
confinement qui s'appelle jules jelade
or c'est vraiment un mec exceptionnel et
je laime très forge de giuly le sait il
est très timide
c'est pour ça qu'il fait très peu
plateaux de télé mais c'est un génie
travaille toute la journée
toute la journée les dans son studio et
à chaque fois qu'on lui a demandé un
truc que ce soit pour aider des enfants
voilà et pierrick g1j un club de un club
voilà je jette d'un club de foot et le
préparateur physique de l'atletico de
marseille et le préparateur physique du
club de foot et fait partie donc là la
sécu de jul et il m'a dit voilà que
c'était un mec exceptionnel aussi et je
l'adoré
oui alors alors moi je vous raconte en
fait quand il a sorti ça prend son
premier disque là elle est l'ovni et
tout ça j'étais de ceux qui se moquaient
d'eux je reconnais quand il a sorti
l'onu c'est quoi c'est quoi ce truc mais
moi j'ai là que j'étais de ceux qui
adoraient pas de joules et au début de
l'année de cette année là où ça je
faisais du sport et les playlists qui
défilent sur youtube et ça m'a mis
directement des musiques de jul à parfum
de quartier il ya d'autres bien d'autres
tubes aussi où je me suis reconnue
dedans et franchement j'adore ce mec
giro j'ai découvert un univers
il se dit marseillais il fait des clips
au vélodrome il n'est pas de ceux qui se
cachent et pas de ceux qui disent bah je
vais pas dire d'où je viens parce que ça
va me priver d'une partie de mon public
si j'étais très trop longtemps parce que
c'est un vrai coup de coeur alors je
vous dirais que le vrai en choeur aussi
de 2,2 de raymond parce qu'elle convient
de sucer la jeanne est rien la reprise
de début de ce nom parce que les
[Rires]
démentis mondiale
quand même et c'est là la livraison
jours c'est pour giuly qui a dévoilé ses
nouveaux centres risquent d'être le tube
de l'été
c'est un remix d'une musique qui
cartonne depuis sa sortie en 89 ses
nuits de folie il a repris une folie jul
qui va sortir un nouvel album la machine
le 19 juin prochain et qui risque de
vraiment cartonné regardez petit récap
de jogging saoul à dire non non c'est
trop long a lancé l'image les appels
l'ovni regarder c'est ce qu'on appelle
une rencontre musicale des plus
inattendues l'un des rappeurs les plus
populaires de france avec ses 3,5
millions d'albums écoulés depuis le
début de sa jeune carrière vient de
reprendre un titre culte des années 80
de son signe de la main culte à ses
douze albums studio jul occupe le
terrain et fait danser les français il y
a quelques jours il a d'ailleurs dévoilé
un titre de son nouvel album un titre
pour le moins surprenant puisqu'il
s'agit d'une reprise de nuit de folie du
groupe début de soirée
un titre dont il a modifié quelques
paroles
[Musique]
un titre divertissant qui semble
beaucoup amuser ses fans
et j'adore on peut la voir la nouvelle
sur un stade où le regarder
[Musique]
bah tant mieux
il était
m'ont pas trop d'avis
[Musique]
réussir quel
g
je l'adorais français bernard cela dans
tous les ça ça va être un énorme carton
ça c'est le carton de l'été un giuly ont
cherché le tube de l'été
ne cherchez plus et ça c'est sûr et
certain seydou le bravo en tout cas il
ya la moule à gâteau si un qui va être
ultra la société ouais c'est bien parce
que giuly vous savez qu'il a il a aussi
fait c'est lui qui a fait la moue la gav
est que 100 fois rien c'est à dire non
vous savez pas qui votent de jul va
avoir les deux tubes de l'été voilà et
son le rappeur français qui a vendu le
plus de disques il ya lui et envié
laissé en téléchargement ses lignes au
ténénio numéro un d'où le numéro deux
mais je suis allé le coup de griffe
oui quel et vouliez dire quoi d'abord je
voulais juste préciser que pour ma jun
est pour beaucoup c'est le génie de la
musique des temps modernes alors
déplaise à beaucoup dieu le garde
toujours la même base et on s'attend
jamais à ce qui va sortir après c'est un
des artistes qui sort le plus de musique
aussi rapidement les unes à côtés 0,3 et
il est hyper proches hyper proche de son
public il les fait participer il les
fait choisir c'est d'ailleurs génotypés
à la aux choix de la pochette de l'album
il avait voté les gens et tout j'ai
trouvé ça hyper lui dis toi et vraiment
il est top et il dit lui même je me
dépêche
il dit lui même qu'il est nul mais que
justement il fait lorraine je le trouve
génial